لا يمكن لاسرائيل ان تقدم على اغتيال قاده
من حزب الله وضباط بالحرس الثوري الايراني
في سوريا ولبنان من دون ان تحتاط لذلك وان
تاخذ فيه حسبانها تداعيات افعالها هل يعني
ذلك ان اسرائيل جاهزه لفتح جبهه الشمال في
الحرب الجاريه ما احتمالات ذلك استمعوا
لتصريح رئيس الاركان الاسرائيلي اثناء
زياره المنطقه الحدوديه مع
لبنان م بون لا اعلم متى ستبدا الحرب في
الشمال لكن استطيع القول لكم ان احتمال
حدوثها في الاشهر المقبله اعلى بكثير مما
كان عليه الوضع في الماضي واعتقد اننا اذا
بداناها فسيكون ذلك بنقاط نتفوق فيها
عليهم
بكثير يقول موقع ولا العبري انه استعدادا
للحرب فالجيش الاسرائيلي يعد خطه جديده
لاجلاء اكثر من 100000 شخص من المستوطنات
القريبه من الحدود الشماليه مع لبنان
وسيتم توزيعهم على المستوطنات
البعيده رئيس بلديه
نيشر طالب السكان في مدينه حيفا شمال
اسرائيل سكان المستوطنات القريبه من
الحدود بتخزين الطعام استعدادا لامكانيه
نشوب الحرب مع لبنان وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي يوف جالان اكد لنظيره الفرنسي
ان حزب الله لو اوقف اطلاق النار فان
اسرائيل لن تفعل المثل حتى تضمن عوده سكان
الشمال اقدر ان مواصله القتال في الجنوب
ستؤدي الى استمرار القتال ايضا في الشمال
لكننا لن نقبل ان يستمر هذا الوضع الى
فترات طويله قادمه لهذا ستاتي اللحظه التي
اذا لم نصل فيها الى توافق ينص على احترام
حزب الله حق السكان في العيش هنا بامان
فعلينا ان نجلب هذا الامن عبر
القوه بالمقابل نائب الامين العام لحزب
الله اللبناني نعيم قاسم قال في خطاب له
عندما تق قرر اسرائيل توسعه العدوان
ستتلقى الجواب بصفح كبيره وبعمل قوي يجب
ان يعلم يعلم العدو ان جهوزيه الحزب عاليه
جدا اما بالنسبه لتعليقاتكم على هذا الجدل
جبهه الشمال فتقول مايا اسرائيل غير قادره
على معارك طويله الامد لانه سيكون
استنزافا اقتصاديا وعسكريا سيرهقك ثلاث
جبهات جبهه غزه ولبنان وجبهه اليمن سينه ك
جيشها واقتصادها البحيري قال اسرائيل تهدد
حزب الله يبدو ان الاقليم سيشتعل بالكامل
وستجعل المنطقه فقط لكي يرضي المجنون
نتنياهو نزواته نجوى تقول العدو الذي يقتل
اهلنا في غزه هو نفسه الذي يقتل قيادات في
حزب الله اصبح واضحا من هم اعداء اسرائيل
الحقيقيين رغم كل التشويش والتضليل وحرف
للحقائق الافندي قال اسرائيل ستفتح على
نفسها ابواب جهنم فلبنان حدودها مفتوحه مع
دول الجوار وستت دفق عليها الامكانيات
العسكريه من كل انحاء العالم الرافض
للهيمنه الصهيونيه العالميه التغريده
الاخيره اتت من عادل ويقول فيها لن تكون
هناك حرب بين حزب الله وجيش الاحتلال بسبب
الداخل الاسرائيلي وتحت ضغط شديد من حرب
غزه ولن يحتمل حربا اخرى ضد عدو شرس جربوه
كثيرا من
قبل هذا استطلاع للراي ساريكم
اجرته جامعه تل ابيب والجامعه العبريه في
اسرائيل اظهر ان 44 في من الاسرائيليين لا
يشعرون بالامان بسبب السياسه التي تتبعها
حكومه نتنياهو على الحدود الشماليه لذا ف
65 بالمئه من المستطلع ارائهم يؤيدون شن
عمليه عسكريه ضد حزب الله اللبناني وازاله
التهديد عنهم حتى لو ادى ذلك الى حرب
شامله ضد لبنان